haben sie das eigentlich mitgekriegt die
deutsche china politik ist nur noch ein
scherbenhaufen keine übertreibung die
europäische union hat gerade nach streit
über sanktionen das fette
handelsabkommen mit den chinesen auf eis
gelegt dabei war das doch ein
lieblingsprojekt von angela merkel
unterzeichnet am vorletzten tag der
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft und jetzt
ist natürlich glutamat teuer freunde
heiko maas ned die chinesen systemische
rivalen sie sind aber gleichzeitig unser
wichtigster handelspartner volumen in
2020 über 212 milliarden euro
im und export zusammengerechnet dafür
kann man schon ein bisschen freundlich
sein
zu einem unfreundlichen start wer bei
diesem gespräch den takt vorgibt macht
peking gleich zu beginn klar engagement
können wir anfangen fragt chinas
ministerpräsident sehr gerne sie sind
sie sind jung sie sind ja gastgeber jaja
machen oma wir essen zeitig wie könnte
man unser aktuelles verhältnis zu den
chinesen beschreiben
sagen wir so vor allem fehlt uns da eine
langfristige china strategie wandel
durch handel hat nicht so richtig
geklappt
der handel boomt aber die chinesen
werden gleichzeitig immer autokratischer
und immer aggressiver inzwischen ist
deutschland derartig abhängig vom
chinesischen markt dass man sich kritik
kaum noch erlauben kann
wenn überhaupt dann nur als hohles
ritual und das hat ja schon tradition
wissen wir sagen menschenrechte und dann
sagen die könnt euch da einschieben
wobei der peking ente die füllung
reinkommt dabei spielt das thema
menschenrechte
traditionsgemäß in unseren gesprächen
immer wieder eine rolle hier gibt es
auch meinungsverschiedenheiten man
sollte hier unnötige störungen
beseitigen und an einer win win
zusammenarbeit festhalten dann können
sich unsere beziehungen gesund und
stabil entwickelt eintrag ins
klassenbuch angela stört wiederholt den
unterricht mit unnötigen menschenrechten
sagt ministerpräsident winwin geld aus
china ist im grunde wie eine droge und
deutschland ist mit abstand der größte
junkie von allen
niemand kann die globalisierung zurück
drinnen ist klar aber ich sag mal wenn
die chinesen anfangen was ja fakt ist
kritik an ihrer politik bei uns zu
verbieten dann müsste eigentlich auch
mal schluss sein
gerade gab es einen von china
gesteuerten boykott unter anderem gegen
h&m und gegen adidas weil die keine
baumwolle mehr aus der uiguren-provinz
shin young verarbeiten wollten sie
merken schon in einer welt wo h&m
plötzlich zu den guten gehört da ist was
furchtbar schief gelaufen
chinesische propaganda flutet zunehmend
auch den rest der welt über alle
möglichen kanäle während ausländische
journalisten gar nicht mehr frei
berichten können
aus diesem furchtbaren überwachungsstaat
vor allem nicht über die muslimische
minderheit der uiguren 13 millionen von
denen werden einfach mal als potenzielle
terroristen betrachtet und auch
behandelt
mehr als eine millionen uiguren sitzen
im massiv gesicherten
internierungslagern
china präsentiert sie als
ausbildungslager berufsschulen das sind
im grunde berufsschulen nur halt mit
prügel sklavenarbeit und
zwangssterilisation weil man deren
kultur komplett weg haben will das ist
offensichtlich das ziel und jeder muslim
in der provinz da kriegt tatsächlich
seine eigene sicherheitsüberprüfung und
stahl damit anderen promi
zu beginn haben alle 100 punkte das
bedeutet man ist eine ungefährliche
person dabei dann werden für jede frage
die sie mit ja beantworten zehn punkte
abgezogen
zb sind die uiguren zweite frage kennen
sie einen ruhigeren und wenn ja wo wohnt
der das schlimmste quiz der welt china
die neue weltmacht regiert inzwischen
sogar in hollywood wirklich bestes
beispiel dieser sinnlose film mulan
gedreht ausgerechnet in der region
shenyang mit einer hauptdarstellerin die
bei twitter die chinesische polizei und
ihr vorgehen in hongkong feiert und dann
bedankt sich der disney konzern im
abspann auch noch bei den chinesischen
sicherheitsbehörden und das ist kein
einzelfall
weltweit werden ganze drehbücher
komplett umgeschrieben damit sie den
zensoren in peking gefallen schlimm aber
so läuft das halt heute in der neuen
weltordnung und da kommt selbst mein
alter sender nicht ganz daran vorbei
in der zdf mediathek gab es ja neulich
diese spezial folge vom traumschiff wie
sie wo florian silbereisen einen
taiwanesischen zerstörer versenkt super
oder wetten dass peking diese hongkonger
polizeieinheit wettet dass sie nur drei
minuten 1000 demonstranten von der
straße prügeln kann und eine nagelneue
folge von die bergretter die heißt sorry
wir retten keine uiguren und sonntags
natürlich ist klar der zdf bambus garten
mit kiwi logische zdf mediathek für mich
dass youtube der herzen zu vier buckeln
von china insgesamt neuerdings so da
wird es verrückt neuerdings muss sogar
sat 1 gold die ganzen schönen alten
bonan verfolgen völlig neu
synchronisieren wann der scheiß passat
ist schon wieder kaputt aber wenn ich
den steigen in den auspuff kriege sinken
wenigstens die abgaswerte so laute
ansage vom neuen boss die ponderosa
ranch gehört jetzt mir und ihr macht zur
abwechslung mal die drecksarbeit
das war doch immer dein job vergiss es
ihr schreibt jetzt für mich die handys
zusammen oberhof siegen schnauze
fettsack ich zahle euch den mindestlohn
nicht fürs pause machen so und jetzt
fessel den journalisten dauernd schmeiße
ich mir in den kofferraum
so atmen sie an die berufsschule
bonanza das brokeback mountain meiner
generation aktuelle unterhaltung made in
china sieht dagegen so aus das kino
musical the wings of song zeigt wie das
leben in der uiguren-provinz shin young
laut kp china wirklich aussieht und und
wunderschön
wobei ich war noch nie da vielleicht
singen und tanzen da ja den ganzen tag
ist auch folter zynischer geht es
wirklich nicht
so aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reicher